[Music]
hello and good afternoon and welcome to
scitrek your scifi tv a movie channel
right well
it's been a bit of a mad 24 hours
as far as target goes and um
after the news yesterday that stage is
going to have its own channel on peacock
um i actually found out that is
something that happens if you're in
america something that peacock over does
there peacock um just over there quite a
lot it's quite new over here so we
haven't really got that um but we are
gonna be getting a stargate channel
hey shelly how are you good afternoon
um
so i
also found out that um stargate is
actually on sky tv in the uk which i
also didn't know i was watching it on
sky it disappeared before christmas i
didn't know it would be a bit but anyway
so in my 24 hours but i immediately
after that news because that threw me a
bit this news about
um
sidetrack going on to peacock so i
immediately messaged the people in and
around mgm that i talked to for a bit of
an update about what's going on
i wasn't expecting
quite as much information to come back
so quickly
and for one i've got a couple of
apologies for not mentioning that it was
going on to peacock because apparently
they knew
um
sg-1 is on netflix spring but i believe
that's in america it's not here in the
uk again it was supposed to go off
um netflix though it was big news that
it was going off netflix and it just
didn't happen so i can only assume there
was another deal went through um but
that is actually part of what i'm going
to be talking about
so first of all the people i spoke to
mgm
they were saying as soon as this deal
was finalized last week which was a
little bit of a surprise they genuinely
apparently thought or the feeling with
mgm was that the deal would not go
through that quickly that this woman
that the chair of the ftc this con woman
would um actually
make it more difficult
and they were not expecting the deal to
go through quite as simply but they had
contingency plans for all scenarios i've
talked to you guys about that before
that there were contingency plans where
it come to stargate there was lots of
other projects with exactly the same if
the deal excuse me if the deal went
through quickly don't do this if it went
through slowly they would do this and
united had contingency plans
so as soon as the sale was confirmed
this kicked in apparently quite a lot of
um stuff they did or they'd already
planned
so the mgm employees have told me that
actually there's been lots of memos
flying around sort of clarifying the
position of how this relationship
between amazon and mgm is going to work
now that
um basically this this has gone through
um apparently they have had reassurances
that there are going to be no
redundancies um no big forced reshuffles
of employees and staff and things like
this
but the big thing here is apparently
amazon have reassured the mgm executives
and staff that they're going to continue
to basically only act as a customer that
amazon are not going to force their will
on mgm in any great lengths they're also
not going to force exclusive deals on
mgm
the way that that's been explained to me
is that the mgm staff have basically
said they're still going to be allowed
to do things like um having deals and
partnership deals with other studios
like they do now lots of movies are in
particular mgm the partnership with
columbia or somebody else
now there's a lot of programs a lot of
projects already in that sort of being
done that way and the amazon have no
problem with those deals being continued
i think the main reason for that and
this is only my opinion here but i think
the main reason for that is mgm has so
many deals with tv series movies and
things like this on so many other
different platforms
bringing mgm products off all of those
platforms where there are contracts in
place would be damn near impossible and
probably very expensive so amazon don't
see the need to do that basically or at
least not at the moment
the other thing though that means is
that mgm can actually start
selling its product on all the platforms
this is probably one of the reasons why
the peacock deal was allowed to go
through because amazon actually have no
intention of stopping mgm from doing
things like putting stargate on a
competitor's um
platform if there is a deal to be made
so there's no plans for basically amazon
to take over mgm for mgm just become an
exclusive studio for amazon which
actually was something that was
suspected to have happened um a lot of
insiders and a lot of business um
specialists have been saying this for a
while that mgmw basically just become
studio for amazon that doesn't seem to
be the case
now that's a good thing for lots of
reasons but mainly because mgm is
actually one of the oldest most
successful studios in hollywood it's
it's an institution it would have been a
shame if it had just become a puppet of
amazon productions
so that's not going to happen
as i say when the sale went through
those contingency plans on top of
contingency plans so
as soon as the deal actually went
through a lot of these contingency plans
kicked in
and the mgm policy said all of a sudden
where they've been in limbo with lots of
projects
all of a sudden there was clarity and
they were told very quickly i mean
the one employee told me that within 24
hours of the deal being going through
18 different projects that he'd been
working on and that that wouldn't be
actually specific programs and things
with lots of whatever he's working on
that he's been basically waiting on for
the green light or waiting permission to
move ahead with got greenlit overnight
they basically never gonna crack on with
it and so he was very very happy
um
so lots of clarification
but what does that mean for stargate
well again there was actually some
really big dramatic news almost
immediately
as you know if you're a regular
sidetracker to the channel
over the last and 12 months or so
stargate and actually two years because
i mean it went into a sort of a limbo
due to covert initially but then last 12
months because of the sale to amazon
the target project has been in limbo
like lots of other projects though mgm
had been considering their options
during best limbo period
one of the things they were doing was
they were considering alternatives to
brad wright's script
amazon came in and also said that
actually this script that they saw could
be have a slightly grand it could be a
little bit more um ambitious
but white seems to have listened
and we know from joe melosi who tweeted
just a few days ago
that um there is a second script and
it's been completed and we know that
that second script is actually an update
of the um original so brad wright has
actually rewritten
the original pilot
that rewrite seems to have gone down
very well
some point at the end of last week this
mysterious second script who we still
don't know who wrote it i believe joe
malozy's name is on it but
i was told that he was attached to him
somehow but he has actually
been asked by one of my amazing
subscribers directly do you know
anything about it and he's denied it but
to be honest he probably would anyway
but
also i don't know for certain name was
attached to it um but this mysterious
second script
um was being planned for some pitch
meetings next week and there was some
art being produced for it for for the
pitch meetings
they got scrapped immediately so those
that script is not happening
um
there were doubts and that's been
confirmed to me again today that there
were doubts over brad wright on whether
he should show run
but those doubts really did come from
amazon and initially mgm
um basically thought they had to
cow down to mgm's to know what amazon
wanted it now turns out the mgm are more
than happy to follow mgm's lead or
amazon and follow follow mgm's lead and
allow them to make creative decisions
this is this has allowed mgm to actually
make a decision
and it looks like my decision is to go
with brad wright's pilot
or in particularly because he's done
this rewrite that has been really well
received
so as we stand right now
brad white's project is the only one
being considered
brad wright is by far and away a lead
runner to showrun the new stargate
series
there are no other projects in line
there is a plan for um a movie and
potentially a plan for prequel
but neither of those projects are being
pushed forward right now mainly because
brad white's project is far enough along
it's the project mgm always wanted to do
and now they've actually been told that
they're going to be allowed to go ahead
with it so
all happy days
um i'm just checking it in the end thing
i've seen some of the comments that are
coming up for the very strange
somebody's talking about mars i don't
know what that's about but we'll leave
it um
so to move on
joseph malozy's always also being quite
active on twitter he was asked very
directly again or what stage are we at
how many chevrons are encoded for us can
we get stargate he said a couple of
years ago it was five chevrons encoded
but the sixth seventh chevron are the
hardest ones he said it's still five
show five chevrons but he actually went
on to say
that stargate coming back was inevitable
now that is a hell of a thing to say
publicly from somebody that was an
executive producer and somebody's very
heavily involved in stargate he talks a
lot about target he's on star world and
stargate um podcasts and things all the
time talking about the projects he he
adores it so if you say it's inevitable
really underlines what we've been
talking about for the for the last 12
months about how stargate is almost is
100 going to be coming back to our
screens in what form well we're now
starting to understand what form because
brad wright has kind of told us
so there'll be no movie no prequel brad
wright is the only one in the running
right now
i actually put a little vote
on the channel early on the community
page it got 39 votes it's only been a
couple of hours but 39 votes i basically
asked do we think brad wright is the
right man to lead stagger into the
future and 95 of the people that voted
that said oh hell yes
so
the peop us fans are very excited about
this i want sg-1 and stargate atlantis
brad right i don't want stargate
universe brad right but from what joseph
melosi has said about what he because he
has read the script
and that there is humor that it's a
funny script he says the antagonist is
really interesting it's fantastic sci-fi
and it's nice to see some of the old
faces back as well which we know from
what brad wright has said on his podcast
that at very least general carter is
going to be making an appearance
now to go on to a couple of rumors
now these are rumors i do get yelled at
sometimes
for um saying things are not making it
very clear when someone is a rumor so a
rumor
um is that richard dean anderson is very
interested in actually coming back and
working on brad wright again it is
confirmed that he is going to be doing a
read long
script on um brad wright's podcast with
amanda tapping and michael shanks and a
few others
but that is leading towards him making
some appearance on this new stargate
project
again a rumor now
i actually think that makes sense
for me
i would love to see
him married to general carter
um finally they will they won't wait
something answered
um but also he won't have a big part it
will be a bit part he'll be a retired
general
they will be maybe going to him for
advice or something along those lines
and he will have a small partner but i
just want to see him come on crack a few
jokes
and and potentially and and head off
this is a man who is in his 70s come on
people um you know he's not gonna have a
massive part in this um but he's
actually officially never retired he
still does little projects here and
there he does a lot of um volunteer work
and he's really um quite a
um
he's an environmentalist basically does
a lot of work for the environment um but
i could see him most definitely doing
something like those like that
um it is still under consideration that
um amanda tapping's part won't be huge
it'll be i think roughly like what
richard dean anderson um did towards the
end of his time with stargate where
he'll come in for that episode
she is being tapped up no pun intended
to direct um but also potentially to be
an executive producer
i could con completely see that working
and being a very popular decision with
fans again if he decides to do that
so
where are we at right now well
there are still meetings planned for
next week between executive producers of
amazon and mgm
those will be very much involved with um
light in certain projects
including apparently and there is going
to be at least one day set aside to
discuss
stargate and another project
um there are obviously massive movie
projects and deals like this that will
need to be discussed as well
um along those lines apparently
what i'm being told is the decision to
make stargate has basically already been
made
um which is quite actually makes me go a
little bit um
it's it's a long way from getting to the
official green light when they can
actually start pushing ahead with this
though because if you think about that
they have to think about
a pilot they have to think about what
budget they want to do they have to
think about um getting they get like the
chief executives and things to sign off
on these things um so it's a long run to
actually get to the green light bit but
the basic decision to go ahead and
actually do this
seems to have been made but they are
going to be bringing stargate back
the beautiful thing about a tv series
rather than a movie
and which was apparently the plan for a
few months so that's generally what they
thought amazon wanted them to do and
amazon apparently did quite like the
idea of doing a movie first
is that tv series can be on a screen so
in six months
a movie would take at least 18 months
if you think about it from back in the
day they used to produce 22 tv series 22
episodes uh a year
and that probably won't be the case um
i'm being told again
by i think that the chances are
um
[Music]
traction overnight screens
eight nine months
if they really if they decided in the
green lit it soon from green lights to
honest greens
six to nine months depends on how much
how much they want to do
um
the um
it would be probably 10 or 12 episodes a
series
it would be along the lines i was
talking about in the last video about
how um trying to do each little series
would have a very specific plot
um and that
they would be then potentially if that's
popular or the project would come along
quite quickly including potentially the
ancients prequel series
but the idea being that whatever
projects they do would influence other
projects
the game is also going to be quite
important on this because the game has
been put back a couple of times stargate
timekeepers
um and they again that game coming out
they will want to have something green
lit or something they can announce
around that time
again today i've been told that july
27th the 25th anniversary of stargate
sg-1 airing on our screens
is a big date
and amazon would love
and they basically the marketing people
would love to have something green lit
by that date
so please guys get in the comments
really quickly that's all the news i've
got for you um obviously so it's a short
video today but if you've got any
questions if i can answer them i will
and my phone has literally been going
off constantly while i've been at work
today it hasn't bloody stopped i've got
pages of notes of things that that's
been
jumped on
um
but but yeah um that's basically
what we where we're at right now
um just by a quick thumbs up as well
everybody's watching right now how happy
are we that brad wright is going to be
involved
like i said i want sg1 and sg atlantis
brad right i don't want sgu atlantis
so come on get into comments really
quickly tell me what you think
and i will just double check i haven't
missed anything
[Music]
nope
that's it
so everybody is going nuts into the
thing very happy thanks for the update
wiki by a thumbs up retro arena
so thank you very much guys i am so glad
to be able to give this news because it
really is exciting um
it's it's how mad is it to actually say
and to be
my confidence is like
98 confident that we're gonna know
something about this
in the next
two or three months
i mean not just no like
confirmed definite 100 green lit
filming casting all this sort of thing
that's an amazing thing to get from
where we were when this got first
announced when brad white first nearly
three years ago said he was working on a
script
to now i mean i was done generally
starting to worry um two or three months
ago this one's going to happen
um there seemed to be so many
conflicting stories going on so many
conflicting things
and
sgu right
off the cliffs sgu d was getting better
but it was my least favorite and still
stargate that's still stargate
so i mean it's still better than 99 to
show it out there
it just
wasn't funny and it it was too dark and
it was too serious for me it lacked
the x factor of sg1 and sg
stargate atlantis and that x factor was
a bit of comedy
and that's what it missed which is why i
love joe melosi saying that actually
there's a lot of humor in this new tv
series so
fantastic
anything love it okay guys i am going to
run
i'm straight at work
i'm naked
i'm going to go get some sleep
um
i've not done very well and i'm still
doing this work so i just wanted i was
excited to be able to tell you guys this
so please
if you are new to the channel like
subscribe hit the bell notification hit
thumbs up on the video don't hit thumbs
down thumbs down here it's nobody and
i will catch you all next time
please
share the video wherever the hell you
like everybody stay safe and i'll see
you really really soon thanks guys